but that is um a photo of you what a
friendly looking guy right there yeah he
couldn't even smile
what what investigator would do is like
if that was uh part of a crime
investigation
run a search and see uh
you know
any information so we just confirm that
photo okay and now it's searching over
20 billion images on the open internet
so these are all things that are
uh open so if you want me to click on a
photo to see more
uh you you do
that photo
so how different is this than google
images
well it's google images doesn't search
based on faces you can go to type the
name in and look at images
so you know that case that is uh
investigating that uh child pornographer
in is in the background of another photo
he didn't tag himself in that so i'm
glad you guys got joker in the back by
the way that's the best joker heath
ledger yeah
so how many how many pictures came up
how many pictures are you seeing here
come up
99 results there are more but like we
have our system cut off at a certain
point okay so let's just say i am
working for an agency so what do i do
now
so for example you might be in uh
say this was a criminal investigation
where you're trying to identify a
suspect sometimes it's a victim too so
uh you know especially in child
pornography cases they don't know who
the victims are you're trying to find a
name of a person right so
in this case
can i click on that one sure
this goes to a website and that website
might have information about the name so
here we can see that your name patrick
that david
and it's you know
an instagram profile so this is
who that is that's actually britney
kaiser who was a whistleblower for
cambridge analytica yeah i don't know if
you're familiar with her i've heard of
cambridge analytica so let's do let's do
a couple of other guys that we have here
so
um
we'll see
so google for faces okay
kai good for you guys this guy's got a
nice smile from norway how do you not
love that guy
and thanks to kai for volunteering yeah
thank you kai tyler again it's only
anything that's out there
that's public
kai you're officially in the system just
so you know
well all the photos that i uploaded
don't get added it's only searching the
other systems let's see what comes oh
you got a picture right there when he
was younger top right
okay this is us
but if you go to
all right
keep going
who is this kai what are you doing does
that appear
okay oh my gosh kai
all right so let's uh uh
yeah that's starting to really concern
me that picture right there we gotta
have a conversation with kai
yeah well
yeah in the context of uh you know
investigation for law enforcement you're
just trying to id someone right yeah or
also verify who it is say is you have
eyewitness lineup right things like that
this can be a way more accurate way to
id people
um and so that's how the system works in
a nutshell so if you take this context
of uh you know someone robbed a bank
right uh someone shot somebody and all
there is is video footage and you don't
have a name yeah you know i wouldn't use
this tool and this data set so i think
that's the part that people miss a
little bit because you have to dig into
the context around it
and so
and we think there's a lot of great
applications of facial recognition that
are protective of consumers that are
often right what if when you signed up
for your bank account you opted in to
have your photo so whenever there's a
large transaction of ten thousand
dollars or more that it does a facial
recognition check so i think there's two
sides to the technology uh and that
side's a the less controversial one um
and that's a great way to prevent why
why is the majority of the world okay
with all the other stuff but now would
work not with what you're doing
why are people okay with going to the
bank take a picture hey can we do this
sure hey i'm gonna go get my id the envy
takes a picture or whatever i go to this
place that's fine why are why are people
comfortable with that but so many are
not comfortable with you well i think
there's two parts of the innovation one
is the law the size of the data set
right uh that was 20 billion images and
20 billion you were just at three
billion you guys are at 20 billion three
there were ten now at 20 years holy moly
and so in this context every photo is a
potential clue to you know exonerate
someone uh help solve a crime uh and so
i think that's part of it and it's
really accurate now i if you look at the
history of facial recognition in 2011
2012 facebook had tagged your friends
but they only had to be accurate one out
of a thousand you might have a thousand
friends on facebook then apple did
unlocking your phone but that's only
matching the same photo and what we were
able to do was search millions or
billions of photos accurately these are
more um that's a harder problem to do so
i think those are the two things that
made people more concerned um and we're
living in a time now where technology
companies were very beloved in the 2010s
right google and facebook they couldn't
do anything wrong and i think rightly so
that a lot of people now have a more
critical eye towards technology
especially big tech if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]